I'm 36 I'm dating you know a nice girl
closer to my age stable mentally
connected what's to be expected of
myself in the mental state not having
the Thrills of dating a 26 year old and
more of the consistency of dating
somebody older more mature and more
stable with no she's 34. and she got any
kids no no kids has she talked about
children to you she has she's not
hard-pressed to do it she's very
understanding well she's accommodating
right now Greg I'm gonna tell you
exactly what's going to happen at some
point she's gonna be like look I was
engaged I want to have kids where are we
going like where do we stand sort of
thing and then your whole oh she's a
compliant you know companion goes out
the window and then you're going to be
forced to make the choice okay well do I
break up with her and go back to a
younger check that's going to be cool
with the whole travel companion thing or
do I fold and married this chick and
start putting babies in it that's why I
got divorced the last time you're
probably better off dating a younger
chick then and just putting some solid
frame around her